les séries là on arrive sur laurence
peraud laurence peraud soyez pas trop
loin si vous avez sur moi moi je suis au
bout de ma ville la semaine dernière oui
tu nous as dit que tu cherchais un mec
avec un débat n'a ni mal elle n'était
pas pressé va chercher une compagnie oui
avec un descriptif bien précis de la
personne que tu cherches mais je pensais
à ce que tous les auto la table ils ont
peut-être une surprise pour toi mais
regardez la wii avec vous la mecque ou
un rugbyman mec qui aime bien moi
j'allais de sa qui aime bien rigoler
quand même faire l'amour tout ça un beau
quand je craque sur quelques effets
plutôt un mètre soixante dix c'est très
bizarre battu halak n alors
laurence la saint valentin ça se prépare
maintenant c'est le 14 février à une et
en est là c'est la semaine prochaine
donc la lolo c'est maintenant que tu
dois trouver ton mais qu'est ce que tu
auras une semaine pour tomber amoureuse
de lui ouais et sache que tous les
chroniqueurs non taux ramené un trait
d'union
ouais ouais oui chez vous aussi vous
allez donner votre avis bien sûr hashtag
elle juge le grand barca et vous nous
donner votre avis chaque chroniqueur
tard amener quelqu'un alors sache
laurence vraiment que je les comprends
bah oui oui c'est quand on me parle
comme ça il ya plus personne suit
partout alors une espèce de boule
d'émotion tout le temps mais c'est
récolté une boule d'émotion le problème
c'est clair souvent le corps d avec
fabien locker vous savez un prétendant
vous avez ramené quatre garçons alors
jazzy ans à pas lent le symbole johnny
s'appelle huningue à la libye goût de
ses candidats qu il a un âge moyen la 57
57 - johnny la sage en sept ans parce
que par exemple parce qu'il est capable
d'avoir amené le vrai ce temps j'ai 56
ans il a 56 ans pas 50 attendu et sans
qu'il sache en grand chose alors johnny
je vous trouve bien j'aime bien il ya du
dynamisme
j'avais la du style était de taille mais
grand coeur je suis fait dans l'habitude
pas très original cieux je travaille
dans les assurances et ben alors c'était
oui bien sûr c'est une citation jeudi je
n'a pas besoin des célibataires johnny
oui c'est d'héberger une femme quatre
enfants me baiser
et moi j'ai un petit mois s'est passé
lui et moi c'est un petit coup de coeur
pour john rambo 2 buts au dollar il est
génial
alors non sont inquiètes inquiète donc
ça est ce que ton côté rock'n'roll il
est juste dans ton band and how dans ton
esprit et dans mon coeur mais dans ton
slip
laurence pour l'instant johnny reste
d'accord johnny tu vas te mettre à côté
de moi moi moi johnny je te le dis j'ai
eu un petit finning rectorat trahi en
ami tu vois pas ce que pour laurence
j'aimerais bien j'ai rien à voir avec un
mec comme johnny je trouve sympathique
ouais bon couple étoiles ou pas les
seuls je comprends pas oui l'honneur
l'honneur intenable modèle réaliste mais
elle aura les chiens c'est la passion va
bouffer mon cas on me l'a pris dans ses
bras cassé mon cas et vous et vous
johnny pourquoi vous êtes seul mot que
je l'attendais
[Applaudissements]
allez jolie reste avec nous à chaque
fois il ya un prétendant nouveau qui va
régner vous en garderez un parmi les de
janis et john eales et les autres n ya
ni ça dort très bon choix je te kiffe et
à chauny s'est jeté au pire des cas tu
restes avec moi aller le prétendant de
magloire
alors on est à bouaké le prétendant gelé
on s'est parlé à peine donc il ne s'est
absolument rien passé il ne sort pas de
chez moi il s'appelle sébastien et je
sais qu'il va gagner à dax a gagné parce
que il est fan de télé achat
mais avant tout il adore le sport et la
musculation
il aime aussi sa grande passion c'est le
travail bit un peu au chômage depuis
cinq ans mais sa grande passion c'est
quand même et travaille pas des chagos
attend il t'as acheté déjà 3,8 user de
balles et même un magie et surtout 5
legging ma soeur qui me l'ont dit vide
banc et je pense que ce garçon il faut
leur encontre voilà tu es quoi j'ai même
plus envie de le voir
attention à leur encontre et de tuer oui
il s'appelle sébastien c'est le des
médias grecs
[Applaudissements]
bonjour spatiale oui quand même
mais de mon côté
[Applaudissements]
très vite
gianni sorte ami sébastien tu fais quoi
dans la nuit actuellement alors chez un
pote cherche dans quoi parce que
peut-être on peut peut-être aidé au jeu
mais je sais pas trop où tu te tapes là
ça va le faire
et si vous ne voulez pas alors juste
est-ce que vous avez une question à
poser
oui sébastien sébastien au delà de
m'offrir des multi cuiseur et des soi
disant comment tu dis des bahamas 600
délégués
qu'est ce que tu préfères m offrir parce
que s'ils font ça va bon resteront non
feinte c'est une dangereuse et
romantique cette violence il faut
choisir à sauvegarder entre les deux
entre johnny et sébastien pour l'instant
en éliminer un tout de suite
physiquement je choisis sébastien bach
excusez moi je vais être honnête oui
t'as pas vu t'as pas vu johnny tortue 4
sébastien n'a physiquement
kelly s'est fait recaler au repêchage 1
mais moi il est génial c'est sur ce la
mort de ta vie tu cherches cependant
soir mais tu peux avoir un plan coeur un
plan encore si la parenté qui va
descendre les poubelles parce que
sébastien beau gosse qui n'a pas envie
de faire une histoire merci et on peut
pas changer la tête
alors alors elle se garde sébastien bah
oui johnny jean petit fc est johnny moi
je te garde sur wii c'est pour la seule
année johnny remercie belle comme tu es
je m'inquiète pas pour toi
[Applaudissements]
j'te jure en rien des choix encore ça il
derrière chez sema sert pour l'instant
d'accord scène sébastien tu as des
tétons magnifique mais je te le jure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le souci c'est quelqu'un qui est
qualifié tiffen weave à l'infini vous
allez en prétendant qu'il va essayer de
prendre la place de celle de sébastien
je vous aime beaucoup mais c'est trop
facile de venir sans t-shirt honeywell
et où moi je vais vous dire la vérité je
dis qu'il ya un racisme anti beau gosse
d'accord et je suis tous les jours que
sébastien est beau gosse qui des pages
il est beau il est très sympathique
il est certainement très tendue peut
dire qu'il est tout sauf que le mien non
gentille sincère il veut une relation
sérieuse c'est un nounours et il parle
quatre langues évasif
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là et c'est la classe il
vous fait quoi dans la vie je suis
professeur d'université profère
universités où ça en quoi à l'université
de langues orientales d'accord l'idée de
vous parler comme un don de 4 donc la
bande à l'allemand oui chinois mandarin
est vrai alors est ce que vous pouvez
dire ou qui déclaration d'amour d'abord
d'abord en français et après peut-être
au monde arabe
[Musique]
nous admirons des très beaux yeux je
vous ai vu à la télé vous êtes
magnifique
voilà mon poulain ni arabe ni veille à
lyon fait en ml oui déjà
comment peux tu peux dire que sa mère
c'est une fille mais attend il avait
trente ans de télé chez en dégroupant
c'est ce qui nous fait vibrer son
portail est bien une femme intelligente
qui connaît beaucoup de choses dans la
chair
il vient se souviendra de casting non
non non allez tu toi tu sois dit qu'ils
entrent au cp ce1
ifs et yves médaille d'argent de
l'argent est ce qu'ils les professeurs
le cliché le péché
geneviève aussi le cliché
[Rires]
les moulineaux si les moulineaux pas
très bien je vais garder sébastien c'est
dommage c'est voilà je sais pas moi j'ai
un petit bouquin yves merci
sébastien pour la saur qui est notre
grand champion ludivine bon poulain est
juste et juste formidable
vous savez que je me connais plutôt pas
mal en agent de sécurité il assurait la
sécurité de francis lalanne durant c'est
très très belle france il avait une
sécurité il avait une sécurité absolue
non excusez moi qui va attaquer francis
tempéré ne me séduit
jamais je vous demande d'accueillir mon
poulain tilleur si exact
[Applaudissements]
sakho s'est tout d'un coup alors les
mecs air mais les gars juste le peloton
il ya pas mal de lampiste qui tient de
kebab zac merci d'être là
alors à toi la sepa tiffany arrête pas
de maths et tiffany en fait dans le mois
sachs 5 ans zac et oui zac pas de chance
à l'époque important alors merci data
les aimeriez grosse attaque hausse à la
courneuve
j'adore ça provoque
est-ce que tu accepterais d'être mon
garde du corps aulas avec plaisir
merci ça y est j'y allais pas attaquer
tous les jaunes
elle a eu un problème un jour c'est sûr
un mini hachoir celle qu'elle avait
bondi de 40 balles alors qu'il est à 100
20 mai sinon t'emmerde alors regardez là
tu laisses tomber c'est ben ouais t'es
sûr ouais bah écoute seb moshiri n'a
fait quand même tu as fait un beau
parcours
[Applaudissements]
comment ni de loin donc je lui montrais
paris by night ce sport fait quelques
pas de la tour eiffel dans l'ue à
l'heure actuelle qualifiée il ya
d'autres prétendants
tu penses que tu as trouvé la bonne
personne on savoure laurent espérons ça
va être deux salles deux ambiances
s'appelle il s'appelle diamant philippe
ouais il parle russe il parle le russe
il a officiellement 45 ans
officieusement 73 va accueillir ce
diamant ce diamant brut
la poule aux instrus n'hésitez pas à
nous dire si vous êtes heureux du choix
de laurence pour l'instant qui s'est
porté sur sakineh encore le prétend dans
le dos rond et farmine attendant de
crédit donc il restera trois prétendants
que j'ai déjà mis la couleur blanche ne
va pas c'est bien longtemps tu as a tout
de suite
laurence haute a présenté quatre
prétendants pour l'instant tu es content
d'être avec nous au maroc mais sens
minable avec un public enthousiaste venu
quant aux états unis qui boit du thé
voilà et qui est enthousiaste en mai ce
qui se passe ici
non je joue là une définition mais zac
moins cher que célibataire que sur
exactement
laurence et ton style franchement moi
franchement charismatique glamour ya pas
d adjectifs qualificatifs assez forts
pour décrire votre beauté magnifique pas
là
il a trouvé chaussure à son pied alors
qu'il reste encore trois prétendants oui
oui celui de à ce qu'on a connu bien
avant la pub alors il s'appelle bien en
selle diamant philippe il parle russe
diamants il par le russe il nous a dit
qu'il avait 45 ans je l' ai vu je pense
qu'il en a soixante treize jamment
philippe
à 71 ans alors il émane il extrait de
winnie les défauts 71 ans philip wee 71
ans pas se mettre dans cette position
pendant moins d'une heure il ya un mot
d'amour us ya vasselot bilou bovis
hobbit - au gîte votre dossier aux
vastes l'année essentielle n'oppose à
navas voici une trêve agite yanira
chauvat spécialistes qui tiennent à
maladroit de marché je vois oui parce
que sinon aymara le russe en venant ici
alors je me suis dit que peut-être que
j'ai tout blé c'est que j'ai cherché
longtemps qu'on pouvait et que j'ai
trouvée sans chercher le dialogue
le choix est simple et il faut pas
manger moins mais je vais rester sur ac
parce que vous parlez très bien mais les
beaux parleurs garder zac a un côté un
peu marrant tout plat qui n'a pas lâché
sa taille est pas ma pas partir à frire
ou alors elles ont tous accordé ac oui
merci alors si vous avez
j'adorais bientôt papa bien évidemment
de laquelle laurence le couple ses
lumières que lens a choisi aussi le
prétendu de ludivine allez laurent
baffie alors alors qu est ce que tu
aimes manger beaucoup à aa
mais avec lui tu vas manger c'est une
fine bouche c'est un gourmet il choisit
ses femmes par rapport à au bout qui va
avoir
elle va adorer sa forêt noire lors il a
vécu à caton catalan une vraie blonde il
a vécu avec un boudin créole
il rêve d'une pintade le voici
[Musique]
j'ai mis des délits pas mal étant ramené
en sosie double ça a il est beau gosse
revient alors les ducs est super dans
l'est de mercier voitures des voitures
les morts alors tu verras jan reker à
l'arrière ont offert le pot rien d'une
relation pas pourquoi on va vraiment
rémy tu fais quoi dans la vie tu es donc
je suis en voiture
est-ce que laurence vous plaît bah ouais
si j'avoue et elle est bonne ça part
tout seul je n'aime pas c'est moi
j'avoue mais vous êtes beau gosse
franchement vous vendez de belles
voitures
comment je suis la terre c'est le bâton
[Rires]
écoute ma femme
[Musique]
côté passager s'est uni avec ta femme
voilà c'est fini elle est morte parce
que je crois qu on a un petit peu marre
de moi des fois je suis un peu à 6,3 me
casse couilles mais je peux être super
gentil l'holographie a dit que tu aimais
manger ouais mais tu m'as manger bon pas
normalement je mange un sandwich au thon
mais aujourd'hui que ce caviar jeu
je suis leur histoire alors nous alors
non je gardais ac je vous dise
grâce à cette émission avait créé la
grosse rigolade je vous le jure que je
pense qu'on va faire une nouvelle
émission avec laurent baffie
on va y trouver des coûts compass secret
des couples
on va faire un espèce de tournez manège
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très bien mais ce qu'on te voit passer à
l'antenne une émission je vais garder
zac mois passé en gare il est mort moi
je
j'adore son côté décalé active et tout
ce qui à ce qui se passe il est mort de
rire à l'intérieur mais il reste comme
ça je le sais
bravo à l'est le dernier pas mal je suis
comme ça a été génial sachs et c'est sûr
tu es finalistes et finalistes qui reste
c'est un des prétendants c'est kelly
vdev dit qu'il ya quelqu'un a présenté
alors sur avis ce soit moi la dernière
parce que je sais que j'ai le bon j'aime
y trouver la perle rare
donc oui je sais c'est dans les vieux
pots qu'on fait les meilleures
confitures chaput il est passionné
d'écologie
ça c'est vraiment un bon point pour ça
parce que je sais que tu adores
l'écologie même si tu venais même s'ils
partent en plastique il a 75 ans il est
magnifique et ont même déjà je vous
présente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en tout cas tu vous avez la classe d
merci c'est un meilleur deuxième et
troisième aux 1re 2e 3e classe métier
cette quadra dont je t'ai libraires
d'ailleurs la lecture villages à la
neige
c'est vrai alors il paraît que vous avez
écrit des blagues dans les bonbons créé
marceau lui ment c'est vrai 404 semblait
connaître des prostituées
quand elles se disputent les autre chose
qu'à la grosse rigolade dans la peau
merci merci ces gens le prennent aux
arthur quel est le point commun entre
365 peu neuf et 365 capote il pompe que
les deux noms à naples goodyear assez
bas
sa part le gentil finiront de l'année
laurence arthur moi j'ai il a une voix
magnifique
il est beau pis si jamais le soir tapas
il a plus envie de faire l'amour parce
que peut-être qu'à une certaine
génération se fatiguer mais au moins tu
t'ennuies pas parce que tu te raconte
des choses des blagues il envie de
baiser voilà je vais vous dire les
séries je vais vous donner à chacun 30
secondes avec laurence en face à face
d'accord je vous allez vous approchez de
laurence magloire tu peux des décalages
problème c'est qu'on va démarrer par
thack tu as passé trente secondes avec
l'orientation aux accidentés sur lens
allait laisser les laisser l'amour par
les voilà d'amour parler je pense que
l'amour prend du temps pour s'affirmer
s'exprimer pour s'inscrire dans la
continuité d'un grand corps malade et
que dire de plus
ben pour faire court parce qu on a 30
secondes au plaisir de manger à tacos à
la courneuve avec vous c'est sympa de
suite si zac qu'il faut pas le rater ce
que tu veux le faire un petit bisou
comparons pas du tout le premier baiser
c'est tout de suite eu c'est ballot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
il ya quelque chose oui c'est moi au
téléachat m6 j'essaye tout ce que je
vois donc si je me laissais mais génial
c'est pas possible je peux pas alors sur
a les crocs seconde avec laurent sédogo
pour faire tourner la tête des jolies
femmes
on a failli j'attends je leur dit
qu'elles ont un joli profil et moi tu me
regarde de face le jeu l'asie du sud-est
quand les lotus auprès des bagages à
laquelle ils avaient tué
c'est joli il est près de moi ça va être
la révélation peut plus bouger le
monsieur là
ce que je vais faire une déclaration à
nancy l1 t'attends tu vas te calmer pour
l'instant aurait le jeu n'est pas de
revenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je pense qu'on n'a jamais autant rigolé
non c'est mais chaque semaine on passe
des caps
c'est vrai je me disais aussi ses
ceintures et sacs déjà je voudrais vous
remercier tous les deux ans non parce
que arthur vous avez été formidables
j'aime beaucoup votre classe battant
atlanta brassac
non c'est un pote à moi il est bourré
commerce avec le maire de percé c'est
vraiment et j'ai passé un moment
délicieux a aussi merci parce que tu
respires la gentillesse ah mais c'est
vrai balade être un amour de mec tu es
très fair play et j'ai jamais passé ce
moment à tes côtés
tu veux te le dire je t'aime beaucoup à
[ __ ] moi je pensais que ça pouvait se
faire plaisir et se faire plaisir alors
les séries ce sont les deux finalistes
juste lens j'ai une première question à
se poser est ce que d autres prétendants
que ces données sont encore là c'est
quelque chose que je n'ai jamais fait
dans ce parce que c'est tout simplement
la première fois que je fais cela faire
le rappel du bisou non s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît arrêter là laurence
machine tu peux me ramener 2 alors alors
est ce que tu veux ou pas du tout tu me
dis non soit effets semblent donner mais
tu me dis mon choix est fait en amont
philippe dit la vérité gracieux s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît laissez-les
ouais ouais je testerai bien sébastien
le monde
voiture est ce que vous pouvez me
ramener rémy et sébastien
[Applaudissements]
non mais
je vous adore sais pas s'ils voulaient
du tout sébastien alors je voudrais
passer 20 secondes avec toi vas-y celle
là pour toi ma gloire il sait pas ce
qu'ils doivent faire sa ba ba rivage
gondole micro ou par l'eba seconde même
si tu me draguer non je pensais que
c'était fini et moi y avait juste en moi
c'est en fait un ouais j'en rapide toi
je vais t'appeler mon lapin à la fin de
la ceiba c'est ce que vous avez envie
d'embrasser lance bien sûr mais lorsque
tu as envie d'embrasser c'est bien sûr
ben ouais aller mais pour ça je peux pas
aller lâche ton micro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais bon c'est bien c'est loupé jeremy
battue c'est le dernier après parce
qu'ils ont là une émission à faire il
m'a dit vous allez à beat hefti zizou
que tu as envie de l'embrasser
non non t'as pas envie si jamais tu as
un truc avec nous ça sera plus tard
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez pris votre décision
oui alors lance juste après la pause
vous nous donnerez votre décision je
suis un fou de lui coller un petit peu
en avance sur la saint-valentin puisque
c'est une émission autour de l'amour et
oui alors elle n'était pas prévu comme
ça non sa chaîne comme l'émission
n'était pas prévu comme ça ce n'est
qu'ils pas célibataire tu te regardais
l'émission on leur en sera à sa pour le
moment on a décidé de s'atteler à
laurence pérou sans gêne et hyper au
quai sur m6 tous les matins m6 boutique
est apparemment laurence elle en a marre
de vendre elle veut aussi acheter et
mais laurent souffrir offrir son père
laurent boyer est avec nous ils sont
pris c'est l'invité de l'émission et
lolo merci parce que j'ai vu que tu es à
sont pas encore avoir caché avoir depuis
le début de soirée laurence peraud
essaie de trouver l'amour pendant la
pause
laurence m'a dit jean sélectionne 3 elle
a choisi de garder arthur sais rien
ancien libraire sébastien handballeurs
sportif qu'est ce tu fais d'autres y la
recherche la couturière d'accord et zach
qui s'occupe de personnalités dans la
sécurité
cela peut arriver
[Rires]
ma chérie vient au centre de la piste
[Applaudissements]
genre tu va danser en premier avec zac
c'est parti zac
[Musique]
attention deuxième prétendant le
deuxième prétendant pour laurence qui
siègeraient mon amour
sébastien
[Musique]
elle acquit fait attention lausanne et
prétendant qu'est-ce qui se passe
allez place au menu je crois que c'est
un vent qui la touche dans ma loge à
vous disent quelque chose au sérieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avoir toujours été et je suis très
heureux de t'avoir avec nous parce que
tu es formidable
merci beaucoup et à vous aussi laurence
tu vas devoir
après cette épreuve de danse pour en
éliminer un pour garder plus que deux
prétendants à l'élite eu à l'issue de
l'épreuve de danse c'est éliminer
malheureusement zac
pourquoi pourquoi l appât brasseur dont
pourquoi parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
choses qui se sont passées dans les
dents dans les corps dans les énergies
dans les contacts avec arthur et
sébastien non mais ça s'est vu merci
d'avoir été là l'amour de mec est
vraiment fermé bronze à cadaujac placé
deux salles deux ambiances paix à oui on
a un côté on a non sébastien je vous le
dis
chez lui sain ce n'est qu' il est arrivé
et quand je pense qu'il a fait la
différence sur le baiser j'ai senti et
la danse à ses avances et et ben non
celui qui a fait la france on adore ça
arthur en danse j'aime à dire sans
rigoler c'est ryan betty mais c'est vrai
que là tu as eu digne successeur
j'aimerais demander à la production
d'aller me chercher deux chaises on va
mais c'est un petit peu la lumière
ah oui et vous allez sol et oublier
qu'on est tous là que les gens sont en
train de vous regarder alors allez les
filles merci d'avoir c'est joseph et
caroline voilà au verglas dans le bikini
on va vous allez vous m
allez-vous mettre dos à dos pour
l'instant oui je vais demander à
sébastien et arthur devenir a laissé
assez vous venir laurence si on fait
jouer une musique de suspense
oui
deux suspects si vous nous rejoignez sur
s'est vite tu as vu qu'il fit connaissez
certainement laurent stien laurence
peraud qui est sur m6 dans le télé achat
qui est avec nous dans la grande marque
alors en ce que j'aime énormément que je
regardais est venu me voir et m'a dit je
cherche l'amour jeudi laurence à une
semaine de la saint valentin je
m'occupais de torre jeux présentés avec
mes amis une demi douzaine de
prétendants
laurence a retenu deux personnes de
personnes complètement au possible de
personnes qui ne cherchent qu'une chose
et mais parce que ces deux personnes
savent qu aimer c'est ce qui a de plus
beau aimer ses montées mais ta gueule
laurence est ce que ta décision est
prise oui tu veux vivre
laurence el pais la dhabi tout comme si
tu partiras ont dîné avec sept personnes
à 18 heures
en massage en duo avec cette personne et
après ce sera libre à ce que je peux
proposer quand même une catégorie de tu
vas venir
non non pas du tout
[Rires]
ross trois secondes 3 2 à lennon
qu'est-ce que ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci sec
c'est l'heure voilà les abords merci
sébastien bonnet là les amoureux
regardez les amoureux vous avez passage
à des moments de détente
je rajoute dans le cadeau je rajoute un
test le boss c'est bon
merci laurent tu vas prendre ta place et
arthur tu vas attendre sa dulcinée
[Musique]